f heute live herzlich willkommen zu
unserem Ukraine Update in dieser Woche
nach der heftigen russischen
Angriffswelle auf Kiev und andere Städte
in der Ukraine wird die Forderung nach
mehr Unterstützung durch den Westen
lauter vor allem bei der Luftabwehr ein
ukrainischer general warnt vor einem
akuten Munitionsmangel die Reserven z.B
von Patriot Raketen würden nur noch
kurzfristig ausreichen an der Front wird
weiter heftig gekämpft und die Soldaten
klagen über fehlende Munition defektes
Material und dauererschöpfung nach 2
Jahren an der Front wir wollen heute
deswegen fragen wie ist die Lage aktuell
an der Front geht der Ukraine die
Munition aus und entscheidet der Westen
am Ende möglicherweise über den Ausgang
des Krieges darüber spreche ich gleich
mit dem Militärexperten Gustav gressel
und wir schalten zu meiner Kollegin
Alissa jung nach Kiev um zu hören wie
die Situation vor Ort nach dem heftigen
Beschuss ist außerdem wird von der
ukrainischen von der ukrainischen
Führung versucht mit Hilfe von
Headhuntern neue Soldaten auch aus dem
Ausland zu gewinnen wie das
funktionieren soll das wird uns Alisa
gleich erzählen eure Fragen und Gedanken
zum Thema könnt ihr wie immer gerne
direkt im Chat mit uns teilen oder ihr
schickt sie uns per Mail an
zdfheute-live@zdf.de und ich versuche
dann wie immer so viele wie möglich
davon hier im Stream unterzubringen und
aus Berlin ist mir jetzt Gustav gressel
wie eben angekündigt zugeschaltet er ist
Militärexperte beim European Council on
Foreign Relations guten Abend Herr
gressel schönen guten Abend Herr gressel
wir wollen in diesem Stream wie eben
angekündigt vor allem auf die fehlende
Munition uns darauf konzentrieren aber
natürlich auch die Situation an der
Front nicht ganz aus dem Blick verlieren
wir hören von kleinen geländegewinnen
der Russen z.B bei avdka und bei bachmut
unter erheblichen Verlusten wie schätzen
Sie die Situation an der Front aktuell
ein
angespannt also ja die Russen greifen an
sie haben im Grunde in allen
Frontabschnitten die Initiative
die Verluste sind hoch aber natürlich
kostet das auch die Ukraine Kräfte und
vor allen Dingen Munition da ist die
Planungsunsicherheit das schwierigste
auf ukrainischer Seite man weiß nicht
wann weitere Lieferungen aus dem Westen
kommen man weiß nicht wie lange es wird
das heißt man weiß auch nicht wie man
mit dem gegenwärtigen Bestand an
Munition wie lange man haushalten muss
wie viel man jetzt freigeben kann für
Sperrfeuer und das ist natürlich aus
ukrainischer Sicht
problematisch aber Russland hat frische
Kräfte in die in die Offensive
geschmissen und die russische Offensive
selber ist noch nicht erschöpft also wir
haben jetzt die letzten Z D Tage ein
bisschen ein Nachlassen gehabt auch
heute steigen die Angriffe wieder das
ist so das das typische Verhalten wenn
die Russen ihre Truppen rotieren also
alte abgenutzte Kräfte rausziehen neue
frische Kräfte reinziehen und äh die
diese Offensive wird leider noch ein
bisschen dauern bevor sie abklinkt
wenn es natürlich so weitergeht mit den
geländegewinnen werden sich die in
Grenzen halten also wenn den Russen kein
Durchbruch gelingt und es wird auch
diese Offensive so sicher nicht das
ganze Jahr weitergehen dazu sind die äh
Menschen und Materialverluste
schon zu hoch man hat in diesem in
diesem Herbst in etwa schon die die
Neuproduktion
oder Gerät verloren das in etwa der der
Produktion von ganz neuen Fahrzeugen des
ganzen letzten Jahres
sozusagen wiedergibt das heißt man kann
sie natürlich solche solche Angriffe
nicht ewig durchhalten und weiterführen
es wird wieder ruhigere Phasen geben
aber das ja das russische Kalkül
dahinter man erhöht den Druck auf die
Ukraine man erhöht den Druck auf den
Westen neues Gerät zu liefern und da
sind ja die Diskussionen kontroversiell
und wenn hier zu wenig ankommt dann kann
dieser Druck natürlich die Ukraine über
lange Zeit erdrücken
über die möglichen Lieferung durch den
Westen wollen wir im Laufe dieses
Streams natürlich noch weiter sprechen
Herr gressel sie haben jetzt gerade den
den Zustand der russischen Truppen auch
schon angesprochen laut einer Analyse
vom Institute for the study of War
betreffen die hohen Verluste auf
russischer Seite auch eben
Spezialeinheiten also gut ausgebildete
Soldaten sehr stark bedeutet erfahrene
Berufssoldaten machen demnach nur noch
einen kleinen Anteil der russischen
Truppen aus was sagt das über den
Zustand der russischen Streitkräfte und
auch einen möglichen Strategiewechsel
der daraus erfolgen müsste vielleicht
aus ja für eine strategieechsel ist es
für die Eliteeinheiten fast schon zu
spät also also die 76 falschenjäger
divisionenof z.B die wird mittlerweile
zum vierten Mal rekonstituiert das heißt
neu aufgestellt mit neuen Freiwilligen
natürlich ist auch aufgrund der hohen
Verluste an erfahrenen Unteroffizieren
und erfahrenen Offizieren hier die
Qualität jeder Neuaufstellung nicht mehr
dieselbe wie sie am Anfang war auch bei
den Spezialeinheiten die wurden ja auch
oft als reguläre Bodentruppen verwendet
gibt es einen enormen aderlast das heißt
diese die diese Spitzen diese absoluten
eliteinheiten die in Schwerpunkten wie
etwa zuur Abwehr der ukrainischen
Gegenoffensive im Sommer verwendet
wurden die sind jetzt nicht mehr in
dieser Qualität abrufbaren verfügbar was
man auf der anderen Seite auch sagen
muss ist dass die Russen sehr viel
investiert haben in die Verbesserung
ihres Ausbildungssystems und der
Infrastruktur um die mobil gemachten
Soldaten und in Russland läuft eine Art
schattenmobil machung wo also äh
sozusagen in kleinen Dosen aber jeden
Monat eine gewisse Anzahl an äh Leuten
ihren
Einberufungsbefehl bekommen dass diese
Leute besser ausgebildet werden und dass
die sich mehr Zeit nehmen sie in
Verbänden auch zusammen auszubilden das
heißt die
die Qualität der mobilgemachten Verbände
die ist Überzeit durchaus gestiegen das
heißt die das Niveau der russischen äh
Einheit
nähert sich quasi in der Mitte an wir
haben sozusagen die ganz schlechten
Einheiten die nicht mehr so schlecht wie
früher sind und wir haben natürlich die
Eliteeinheiten die lange keine Elite
mehr sind aber auf dem Niveau wie sie
jetzt Nachschub heranführen können Sie
immer noch in in größeren geschlossenen
Verbänden kämpfen und angreifen also ist
leider Gottes sozusagen aus ukrainischer
Sicht der Ofen noch nicht aus personell
dann lassen sie jetzt einmal auf auf die
Reserven bzw die munitionsreserven auf
ukrainischer Seite schauen Kier
verstärkte nach der letzten
Angriffswelle seine Forderung eben nach
neuen Lieferung westlicher Munition und
auch Kampfdrohnen und
Mittelstreckenraketen wie knapp sind die
Reserven ihrer Einschätzung nach aktuell
auf ukrainischer
Seite und die hauptwrung in diesem Krieg
ist immer noch Artilleriemunition
da sind wir jetzt in einer knappen
Situation weil im Westen die meisten
Vorräte also Lagerbestände ammunition
aufgebraucht sind und die neue
Produktion leider noch nicht dort ist wo
sie hätte sein sollen da waren wir
leider auch bei der Budgetierung und bei
der in
auftraggebung von neuen munitionslosen
spät allein etwa wenn man sich die
munitionsinitiative der Europäischen
Union anschaut die ja im März gegründet
wurde aber erst im September kam es zu
Vertragsabschlüssen mit der
Rüstungsindustrie
äh und dementsprechend hinken wir da
hinten nach und das ist bei anderen
Staaten äh und in Amerika leider ähnlich
bei Spezialmunition ist es auch so dass
lange im Westen und damit rede ich jetzt
nicht nur von Deutschland oder nicht nur
von Europa sondern auch in den USA die
Vorstellung Herst dass dieser Krieg
eigentlich bald vorübergehen wird und
dass man keinen langen Krieg führen wird
das heißt man gibt Lagerbestände aus
aber man
äh
sozusagen nur zum Teil kelt man die
Produktion an und das fällt uns jetzt in
gewissen munitionsklassen natürlich auf
die Nase äh weil wir natürlich nicht
eine schnelle Beendigung des Krieges
hatten oder noch kein Ende des Krieges
an sich absehbar ist aber Lagerbestände
von von gewissen Klassen an Munition
sich langsam dem Ende neigen und Patriot
wurde ja schon angesprochen das Problem
natürlich bei Patriot Raketen die
brauchen sehr lange bis sie gebaut
werden ist ein sehr komplexes
Waffensystem das entsteht nicht von
heute auf morgen aber wie gesagt die
großaufträbe an die Industrie neue
Raketen
zu zu bestellen damit die Produktion
angeworfen wird die kamen auch erst bei
den meisten Staaten im Ende des letzten
Jahres
und solange wie die wie die Geräte
gebaut werden müssen ist das natürlich
jetzt bitter weil
wir generell hier einen sehr knappen
bestand haben die NATO rechnet ja
normalerweise damit dass sie mit
Luftüberlegenheit kämpft und das Systeme
wie Patriot oder andere
fliegerabwehrsysteme
punktziele gegen ballistische Raketen
schützen aber sozusagen
nur ja sporadisch Feuerkampf führen
müssen und in der Ukraine gibt es quasi
jede Woche irgendeinen kleineren und
dann alle paar Monate einen größeren
Luftangriff der von der Quantität hier
weit über dem steht was bei uns so an
den planungstischen früher gedacht wurde
dass man die Systeme bräuchte und
dementsprechend ist natürlich auch die
munitionsbevorratung eine andere und das
hilft uns jetzt nicht gerade in diesem
Krieg mm Herr gressel uns fragt jemand
bei Youtube und zwar carlos ist es denn
denkbar dass die unterstützerländer
unangekündigt Lieferung tätigen um die
Russen zu überraschen ist das ein
denkbares Szenario
ähm das tun sie in einigen Fällen äh das
Gerät nicht angekündigt wird beim
Großgerät und bei bei vielen Staaten ist
besondere den USA kriegt das die Presse
schon über kurz od lang mit das hängt
mit haushaltsrechtlichen Gegebenheiten
zusammen dass
gewisse sozusagen Güter ab einem ab
einem gewissen Preisschild ausgewiesen
werden müssen wenn sie verkauft oder
abgegeben werden
ist aber auch meistens so dass die
Presse guten drat in die Ministerien hat
und das rauskriegt als es gibt ganz
wenige Länder die die wirklich dicht
halten über das was sie liefern
und da auch nicht unerhebliche Mengen an
an Munition und und Gerät liefern dass
der Ukraine wichtig ist Finnland wäre so
ein Fall aber in den meisten Fällen
gibt's zumindest inoffizielle Listen was
geliefert wurde okay wir wollen gleich
noch mal weiter über den Nachschub an
Munition sprechen und wie entscheidend
die nächsten Lieferung dann eben auch
für den weiteren Kriegsverlauf sein
können vorher möchte ich mit Ihnen noch
einmal kurz gerne folgende Meldung
besprechen und zwar zwischen der Ukraine
und Russland hat es diese Woche genau
gesagt am Dienstag den bisher größten
Austausch an gefangenen Soldaten gegeben
fast 480 ukrainische und russische
Soldaten konnten jeweils in ihre
Heimatländer zurückkehren das ist jetzt
der erste a Austausch nach sehr langer
Zeit warum ausgerech rechnet jetzt was
sagt das
aus die Verhandlungen über diesen ausaus
gehen die gehen ja schon relativ lange
in dem
Sinn ist es ja überraschend dass es
jetzt kommt aber es war sozusagen die
Gerüchte Küche sagte schon seit längerer
Zeit es wir irgendwann ein Austausch
geben
das eine ist mal dass Russland natürlich
es gab in der Vergangenheit immer immer
häufiger Kritik an der Misshandlung von
Kriegsgefangenen
und an anenthuptungen etc
und natürlich jetzt ist es auch im Zuge
der Raketenangriffe die die
internationale Kritik an Russland wieder
wieder in die Höhe gegangen und da ist
natürlich für für Russland für Moskau
der Gefangenen Austausch ein gutes
Zeichen dass man den Kritikern im im
Ausland sagen kann wir halten uns schon
an internationales Recht also wir
sozusagen sind nicht die Barbaren für
die wir dargestellt werden das ist mal
das eine
das zweite ist die Ukraine will
natürlich ihre Gefangenen auf jeden Fall
zurück weil man genau weil man sieht wie
sie in der russischen Gefangenschaft
behandelt werden und das drit ist auf
der russischen Seite
hängt die Bereitschaft Gefangene
auszutauschen immer sehr stark davon ab
wer da auf der Liste steht den man
eintauschen kann
gerade Spezialisten die eine lange
Ausbildungszeit hinter sich haben die
schwer zu ersetzen sind allen voran
Piloten sind sehr viel wert und wenn die
Ukraine eine größere Anzahl von diesen
Spezialisten gefangen nimmt dann ist die
russische Seite in der Regel will die
Leute einzutauschen Herr gressel vielen
Dank für den Moment wir wollen uns dann
gleich noch mal sprechen und dann wie
gesagt über die möglichen nächsten
Lieferung an Munition und Waffen durch
den Westen danke für den Moment ja in
der Ukraine wird nicht nur die Munition
knapp es fehlt auch an Soldaten die
Mobilisierung von zusätzlichen Soldaten
ist deswegen aktuell ein großes Thema in
der Ukraine um das zu schaffen will die
ukrainische Regierung jetzt neue Wege
gehen fragen wir nachb bei meiner
Kollegin Alisa jung in Kiev Alisa du
hast uns in den vergangenen Wochen auch
davon berichtet dass Soldaten an der
Front über dauererschöpfung klagen und
dass die Angehörigen logischerweise
wollen dass die Männer so schnell wie
möglich nach Hause kommen wie will die
ukrainische Regierung jetzt neue
Soldaten gewinnen und
mobilisieren wir hatten heute die
Möglichkeit hier in Kiev mit einer
Headhunter Agentur zu sprechen die seit
November von der Regierung unter anderem
beauftragt ist sich mit um dieses Thema
zu kümmern wie kann man also Männer
ansprechen die jetzt noch nicht kämpfen
und sie davon überzeugen denn auch für
die Armee dann zu entweder zu kämpfen zu
arbeiten weil es gibt da ja sehr
unterschiedliche Jobs also wie
funktioniert das Ganze ihr könnt das
auch mal zeigen es gibt eine eine
Onlinepräsenz die diese Headhunter
Agentur Lobby Ex zur Verfügung stellt
sie ist eine von mehreren mit denen da
zusammengearbeitet wird und dann findet
man online eine Maske in der man
tatsächlich seine konkrete Qualifikation
angeben kann man kann z.B sagen ich habe
gute Kenntnisse in IT ich habe
vielleicht sogar schon in diesem Bereich
gearbeitet ich kenne mich aus mit
Drohnen also man kann wirklich seine
Fähigkeiten dort zunächst eintragen dann
kann man auch den Bereich anwählen indem
man sich selbst sieht und dann bekommt
man tatsächlich die offenen Stellen
angezeigt wir haben uns das erklären
lassen dass soll in der Tat also auch
kein Sicherheitsrisiko darstellen es
geht also nicht darum zu zeigen oh in
dieser Einheit fehlen jetzt besond viele
Leute das wird also nicht angegeben aber
es wird hier ganz klar jetzt auf
Transparenz gesetzt warum ist das
wichtig viele Männer die jetzt noch
nicht kämpfen die das vielleicht auch
nicht vorhaben weil sie das fürchtet
weil Sie das nicht wollen die versucht
man jetzt zu überzeugen indem man zeigt
ganz klar ihr habt die Wahl ihr bekommt
hier eine Wahlmöglichkeit anders als
vielleicht in der Vergangenheit auch
anders als vielleicht das was den
Männern hier sorgen macht ich werde
irgendwo eingesetzt mit einer Fähigkeit
die ich gar nicht besitze soll man jetzt
hier will man jetzt hier versuchen den
Männern zu zeigen ihr könnt tatsächlich
hier etwas mitbestimmen ihr könnt etwas
von euch hier mit reinbringen und dann
werdet ihr auch entsprechend eingesetzt
das ist also hier ein ganz wichtiger
Punkt wie man transparent auch wieder
Vertrauen aufbauen möchte und damit
natürlich auch Männer im Ausland im
Zweifel ansprechen möchte ob das dann
wirklich großen Erfolg bringt das wird
sich zeigen wir haben heute gehört es
wird in der Tat gut angenommen es gibt
viele Bewerbung und die da arbeitet dann
auch wieder die Headhunter Agentur
zusammen mit der Regierung und versucht
da also diese passenden Matches zu
finden das ist die Idee jetzt erstmal
okay das wäre nämlich meine
Anschlussfrage gewesen du hast es gesagt
es wird bisher gut angenommen also ist
das deineer Einschätzung nach sozusagen
ein Weg von vielen den diese Regierung
möglicherweise jetzt einschlägt oder ist
das eine Maßnahme die da wirklich ja
entscheidend Z zur Mobilisierung
ukrainischer Soldaten beitragen kann wie
würdest du das
einschätzen ob es entscheidend dazu
beiträgt das müssen wir tatsächlich noch
abwarten das gilt es zu beobachten es
ist jetzt wirklich eine Maßnahme die man
ergreift und wo man jetzt auch ein
bisschen was darauf setzt wie man also
Menschen überzeugen möchte aber damit
ist es alleine nicht getan es gibt
tatsächlich und das gab's aber vorher
auch schon es gibt auch Kurse wo Männer
sich bewusst fit machen sich bewusst
trainieren auch körperlich trainieren
weil viele schon auch wissen es geht ja
gar nicht darum dass sie sich verweigern
bei manchen ist auch einfach bislang nur
noch nicht der Fall eingetreten dass sie
jetzt aufgefordert wurden zu kämpfen und
dann wollen sich auch einige vorbereiten
körperlich vorbereiten gehen also
proaktiv in Kurse um sich zu schulen
können aber natürlich auch andere Skills
sein also viele möchten sich hier
vorbereiten dass wenn der Moment kommt
dass sie denn dann eingesetzt werden
sollen in der Armee dass sie dann und
das ist auch wieder die Hoffnung
vielleicht eben eine Wahlmöglichkeit
haben denn in der Tat wird hier in der
ukrainischen Gesellschaft auch darüber
gesprochen welche Einheit hat hier mehr
oder weniger Erfolg das ist hier ein
Thema und so erhofft man sich natürlich
dass wenn man sich auch gut vorbereitet
dass man dann auch zeigen kann hey ich
bin für eure Einheit der richtige und so
möchte man auch dazu beitragen dass man
im Zweifel eben dort eingesetzt wird wo
man sich das selbst auch vorstellen kann
und wo man aber natürlich auch am besten
gebraucht wird eingesetzt werden kann
dass da also keine Ressourcen
verschwendet werden weil es kommt ja
hier auf jeden Mann an jeden einzelnen
solche train Trainings und bis Leute
auch rekrutiert sind das wird aber auch
noch dauern bis zu dre Monate bis man da
überhaupt erst die Männer zur Verfügung
hat und wenn die dann rekrutiert sind
wenn neue Männer da sind dann heißt das
auch für die die jetzt schon so lange
kämpfen nicht dass sie entlast sind es
geht darum dass dann endlich ein
Rotationsprinzip entstehen könnte und
das kann aber natürlich nur entstehen
wenn es auch mehr Männer gibt also
Schritt ein mehr Männer Schritt 2we
endlich diese Rotation ermöglichen für
all jene die jetzt erschöpft an der
Front kämpfen Alisa eine Frage die wir
bei Youtube bekommen haben die ich gerne
noch dazu an Dich weitergeben würde kann
die Ukraine nicht einfach sötner aus dem
Ausland anwerben und somit das Personal
ersetzen ist das was was deiner
Wahrnehmung nach schon diskutiert
wird
also es ist jetzt nicht dass das jetzt
hier aktuell breit in der Öffentlichkeit
diskutiert wird was aber natürlich schon
seit Beginn des Krieges der Fall ist es
gibt Freiwillige aus dem Ausland die
sich in internationaler Legion
angeschlossen haben und auch hier
freiwillig in der Ukraine kämpfen es
gibt es durchaus also es gibt auch
verschiedene Bataillone die aus Menschen
aus dem Ausland bestehen also das ist
schon auch etwas was es gibt aber es
geht ja auch jetzt hier darum die Moral
in der Gesellschaft hier unter den
Menschen weiter hochzuhalten hier
außerdem auch die Ressourcen die
verfügbar sind sind ja auch zu
mobilisieren das ist im Moment die Idee
also die Ressourcen hier aus dem eigenen
Land die jetzt richtig finden richtig
nutzbar machen und richtig einsetzen
dann noch kurz zum Abschluss Alisa in
den vergangenen Tagen gab es ja heftige
Angriffe auf Kiev und auch andere Städte
in der Ukraine wie war die vergangene
Nacht und wie ist die Lage
aktuell die vergangene Nacht war hier in
der Hauptstadt in Kiev ruhig das heißt
nicht dass nicht natürlich weiterhin die
Gefahr besteht eines möglichen neuen
Angriffs sogar möglicherweise einer
neuen Angriffswelle das heißt natürlich
dass die Menschen hier in einer Art
Halbach Stellung sind aber das ist für
die Menschen hier leider ja auch nichts
Neues also es hat sich natürlich jetzt
verschärft in den letzten Tagen durch
die heftigen Angriffswellen dass man
jetzt einfach sehr vorsichtig ist und da
schon natürlich auch jeden Alarm sehr
ernst nimmt und genau darauf schaut was
was passiert was steigt da in der Luft
auf auf was muss man jetzt achten
Präsident sedenski hat vor einer halben
Stunde vor einer guten halben Stunde
auch noch mal ganz klar die Forderung
erneuert was die Ukraine dringend
braucht ist
Luftabwehrsysteme und Munition darüber
habt ihr eben schon gesprochen aber eben
auch neue Luftabwehrsysteme weil man
eben so heftig jetzt wieder auf die
Zivilisten auf die zivile Infrastruktur
zielt ist das natürlich etwas was die
Ukraine aktuell dringend braucht und das
wollen wir jetzt noch weiter vertiefen
vielen Dank für deine Einschätzung und
deine Eindrücke Alissa jung live aus
Kiev danke schön ja wir wollen jetzt wie
gesagt noch mal mit Gustav gressel
sprechen über diese Forderungen nach
mehr Unterstützung durch den Westen die
es aus der Ukraine gibt Herr gressel ich
habe vorgestern an dieser Stelle mit dem
sicherheits- und Militärexperten Nico
lange gesprochen der auch regelmäßig
hier bei uns zu Gast ist und der hat
sinngemäß gesagt die aktuelle die
aktuelle Strategie des Westens Waffen zu
liefern führe eben dazu dass sich die
Ukraine mal gut mal nur sehr lückenhaft
gegen die russischen Angriffe
verteidigen kann aber eben nicht
entscheidend etwas bewegen kann also
salop formuliert zum Verlieren zu viel
zum gewinnen zu wenig entscheidet sich
der Erfolg oder Misserfolg der Ukraine
in diesem Krieg im
Westen zu einem gewissen Teil und zu
einem guten Teil auch ja leider
also wenn wir 2024 wir für die Ukraine
ein enorm wichtiges Jahr die Russen
drücken jetzt an das werden sie nicht
das ganze Jahr tun aber die Ukraine ist
in der Defensive nach der
fehlgeschlagenen Offensive im letzten
Jahr muss man jetzt viele leeren ziehen
muss sich re rekonstituieren man
hat einige Gedanken was den Einsatz neue
Waffensysteme neue Störer angeht man hat
auch einige Gedanken wie man diese
Geräte effizienter einsetzt W man den
kampfd verbundenen Waffen
anders gestaltet mit stärkerem Fokus auf
Drohnen auf elektronische Kampfführung
besser besserer Synchronisation aber
vieles von dem da muss man eben rotieren
also Kräfte herauslösen den angepasst an
den neuen Verfahren ausbilden dann
wieder an die Front
man muss an den eigenen Kommandanten
Arbeiten von denen man viele mobil
gemacht hat die aber ihre ihre
Offiziersausbildung ihre
Führungsausbildung noch in in ich würde
sagen der alten ukrainischen Armee also
D noch stark sowjetisch geprägten
ukrainischen Armee gemacht haben da
gibt's eine lange todooliste die
natürlich die Ukraine auch selbst hat
aber der Westen
ist ja ein erhebliches Teil in diesem
Puzzel und das betrifft erstens mal die
Ausstattung mit Material also was wir
liefern und das zweite ist natürlich wie
wir liefern da gab's zwei Schwachstellen
erstens wir haben das was und wie und in
welcher Quantität und in welchen
Rhythmus wir liefern immer als als
sozusagen als
innerallianzpitische Entscheidung
gesehen also Hausnummer
stat a liefert von einem gewissen Gerät
fünf Stück dann hat sich stat B überlegt
dann liefere ich vom selben Gerät meiner
Größe und meinem politischen Wert
entsprechend dasselbe es gab bis jetzt
keine wirkliche arbeitsteilige
Belieferung man sagt okay aber du hast
in deiner Industrie die bessere
Möglichkeit diese Art von Gerät zu
liefern und auch zu erhalten und
sozusagen der andere Staat oder das
andere Land hat hat eine andere und wir
ergänzen das irgendwie so dass es für
die Ukraine ein rundes Bild zustande
kommt so ist ein Flickwerk zustande
gekommen aus verschiedensten Systemen
und das zweite ist man hat sich z viel
zu wenig Gedanken gemacht wie man diese
diese Systeme dann auch betreibt und
erhält ähm es gibt unzählige Geschichten
es gab ja diese Leopard Geschichte zu
wenig einsatzfähig ähm es ist aber
leider so dass dass das bei viele
Waffensysteme betrifft W panzerobizzen
geliefert jetzt nicht die panzerobitze
aber aber andere ältere Modelle und es
gibt keine Ersatzrohre mehr dafür
die Rohre schießen sich aber mit der
Zeit aus lauter so Kleinigkeiten ähm wo
man sich immer fragt ja was was haben
wir uns eigentlich dabei gedacht äh als
als das Zeug geliefert wurde es muss
doch klar sein dass wenn solche Geräte
in ein Kampfeinsatz gehen der Verschleiß
äh viel höher ist als wenn die jetzt
beim Ausbildungsplatz hier ihre ihre
standardrunden drehen und all all das
gibt es in Westen aufzuarbeiten wir
haben wir fangen jetzt erst an in der
Rüstungsindustrie jenseits von
Artilleriemunition größere Bestellungen
aufzugeben für kampahrzeuge für
Schützenpanzer für Kampfpanzer für
artilleriesysteme
ähm für solche Geräte dauert die
Produktionszeit zwei bis dre Jahre je
nachdem welches Gerät es ist
äh hätten wir zu Beginn des Krieges
schon damit angefangen dann hätten wir
jetzt ähm schon eine weit höhere anzeile
an Fahrzeugen die wir entweder in den
eigenen Streitkräften einführen und der
Ukraine äh älteres Gerät abgeben können
äh oder die wir direkt der Ukraine
zuführen könnten wenn wir es damals
getan hätten aber es wie gesagt die
meisten Politiker gingen davon aus dass
der Krieg äh bald vorbei sein werde und
dass so langfristige Maßnahmen sich
nicht lohnen werden äh weil sie zu spät
kommen und das straft uns jetzt
natürlich bitterlich weil wir jetzt
unsere reservelager was ein Gerät übrig
geblieben ist entweder aus der
Transformationszeit von sowjetisch
Warschau paktgerät zu NATO Standards
oder aus der Transformationszeit aus dem
Kalten Krieg heraus in die nächste
Fahrzeuggeneration diese altlagebestände
sind jetzt im Grunde
aufgebraucht und
wir haben eigentlich keinen Plan und
keine Idee was dem nachfolgt und das
wird 2024 ein extrem schwieriges Jahr
sowohl für die Ukraine und auch für uns
deshalb wir können natürlich wenn wir
die Weichen schnell umlegen
äh da noch mal gegensteuern und
zumindest die die Grundlagen schaffen
dass es der Ukraine dann 2025 besser
geht wenn wieder nichts geschieht und
wenn man wieder nur diskutiert und das
größte Produkt der Europäischen Union
heiße Luft sein wird dann schaut's für
die Ukraine in der Tat bitte aus Herr
gressel Helmut Rosenberger hat uns eine
Mail geschickt und fragt was aus ihrer
Sicht der Grund dafür ist dass das
Kanzleramt die Lieferung von Taurus
Marschflugkörpern bisher
verweigert das ist eine sehr gute Frage
ähm da muss ich ehrlich sagen da bin ich
selber ein bisschen überfragt denn die
Gründe die ja dafür angegeben werden in
der Öffentlichkeit äh die stellen sich
ja alle als als Enden heraus also sowohl
die Frage des politischen Mandats stellt
sich im Grunde nicht weil ja die
Systemintegration also den Ukrainern zu
zeigen wie man das Ding verwendet und
wie man es an ihre Flugzeuge hängt und
technische Adaptionen dieser Flugzeuge
durch den Hersteller vorgenommen wird
und nicht durch die Bundeswehr also auch
die südkoreanischen oder die spanischen
taurusse wurden ja nicht durch die
Bundeswehr ausgeliefert und an
südkoreanische F15 gehängt sondern
sondern durch den Hersteller und das
wäre natürlich auch im Falle der Ukraine
eine Frage für den Hersteller das
bereitzustellen äh dass man Geodaten
nicht herausrücken kann ist auch so ein
komisches Argument also wir geben ja
also der Bundesnachrichtendienst gibt
der Ukraine ja schon klassifizierte
Daten natürlich sind Geodaten für ein
dauus ander ein anderes Format von
klassifizierten Daten aber wir haben ein
Protokoll der Ukraine klassifizierte
Daten zu übergeben andere natostaaten
auch und über die Geodaten kann man ja
aus Deutschland ja auch Steuern wo die
Dinge eingesetzt werden wenn ich der
Ukraine keine Geodaten zur Verfügung
stelle über das russische Kernland dann
kann ich so auch sicherstellen dass sie
im Grunde nur in den besetzten Gebieten
verwendet werden also da sozusagen
widerspricht man sicher selber dann auch
in der Angst die Ukrainer könnte das
einsetzen um um Russland selbst
anzugreifen
ähm ich muss ehrlich sagen ich verstehe
da den Kanzler nicht es gibt im in
Gesprächen mit anderen Leuten mit
mit Offizieren bzw
mit Leuten die im sicherheitsrelevanten
Bereich arbeitet oft andere Gründer die
vorgenommen werden da TA ist ja die
einzige deutsche äh
Fernwaffe mit der man in die russische
Tiefe wirkt im Falle eines äh Angriffs
Russlands auf die NATO deshalb gibt's
natürlich auch viele die
sozusagen gewisse Bedenken haben dass
man
den Taurus liefert erstens wegen den
Stückzahlen zweitens
weil weil die Russen da natürlich sehen
könnten wie das Ding funktioniert wie
wie sehr es das Radar vom Radar sehen
oder nicht gesehen werden welche
Gegenmaßnahmen in diesem äh Flugkörper
verbaut sind etc und das könnte
natürlich die Russen könnten da
natürlich dusus leeren ziehen äh das ist
ein valides Argument das leider
politisch überhaupt nicht auf den Tisch
gebracht wird weil es ja auch die
Lieferung von Taurus nicht unmöglich
macht sondern in eine Debatte ein
betetten würde die jedes jeder Staat die
Franzosen und die Briten ja auch für
sich führen müssen nämlich wenn ich das
Gerät liefer dann müsste ich ähäh eine
Neubeschaffung einleiten also Geräte
nachkaufen
Deutschland by the way hat hätte
eigentlich der NATO weit mehr taauus
zugesagt im Verteidigungsfall als es
derzeit betreibt das heißt wir müssen
eigentlich wenn wir die
natooverteidigung ernst nehmen jetzt
schon neu bauen und wenn wir neue bauen
können wir natürlich das unter
Bedingungen machen etwa von der Ukraine
verlangen dass Berichte über den Einsatz
an Deutschland geliefert werden dass
vielleicht deutsche Spezialisten auch
mit Messtechnik in die Ukraine reisen
dürfen um russische
fliegerabwehrtätigkeiten zu beobachten
oder Elektro elektronisch
auszulauschen damit man für den Taurus 2
oder für eine Weiterentwicklung des
Taurus dann auch valide Einsatzdaten hat
und man sieht ob die eigenen Konzepte
und Gegenmaßnahmen auch wirklich
funktionieren das ist sozusagen wä ja
auch eine charmante Variante all diese
verschiedenen Varianten Optionen werden
aber in Deutschland überhaupt nicht
diskutiert das Kanzleramt grabt sich ein
und sagt im Grunde nichts und was in der
Öffentlichkeit und auf Twitter sonst so
durch die Gegend erschwirt an
Informationen ist äh äh eher zum Kratzen
und das ich habe das glaube ich in einer
Vergangenheit äh vergangenen Sendung
schon gesagt dass unter unseren
Alliierten also in London in Paris führt
das eher zu Verwirrung weil die halt
nicht verstehen können äh wo Deutschland
steht wenn es hier eine offene
Diskussion über die verschiedenen
strategischen Optionen gäbe dann würde
man selbst eine nicht Lieferung besser
verstehen können
das kann man aber nicht weil es keine
Diskussion oder zumindest keine
ernsthafte gibt ja mit diesem
Unverständnis sind Sie nicht alleine das
schreibt z.B auch Frank K bei Youtube
das Kanzleramt will keine effektive
Militärhilfe für die Ukraine ist der
kommentar von Frank K Herr gressel in
der kommenden Woche wollen die
natostaaten in einer Sondersitzung mit
der ukrainischen Regierung über neue
mögliche Waffenlieferung beraten was
erwarten Sie konkret von diesem Treffen
und vielleicht daran noch angeschlossen
welche Waffensysteme Stichwort F16
Kampfjets könnten denn in diesem Jahr
für die Ukraine konkret im wahsten Sinne
des Wortes einen kriegsentscheidenden
Unterschied machen ja einzelne
wachensysteme haben nie
kriegsentscheidenden Charakter ist immer
nur im Verbund die sie geliefert werden
f165 für die Ukraine enorm wichtig weil
ihre Kampfflugzeuge sowjetischer Bauart
schon sehr abgenutzt sind das sind schon
alles ältere Flugzeuge und diese älteren
Flugzeuge wurden jetzt in den letzten
zwei Jahren wirklich sehr intensiv
geflogen das zweite ist dass die
Bewaffnung für diese Flugzeuge also V
allen die Luft luftlenkwaffen die sie
verfeuern
äh fast alle in der in Russland
hergestellt werden zu einem gewissen
Teil werden sie auch in der Ukraine
hergestellt aber nur mit sehr geringer
Kapazität und dass deshalb die Munition
für diese Flugzeuge für diese
Kampfflugzeuge fehlt so ähnlich wie das
mit den mit der Kampfpanzer Diskussion
war wo sozusagen russische Kampfpanzer
oder russische Panzerverbände zwar sehr
viele erbeutete t72 und die80 aus der
russischen Armee haben aber das Problem
war auf dem Weltmarkt Munition für die
Dinger zu finden und genauso ist es mit
den mit den Fliegern ohne ohne ohne
Munition haben die halt n einen
begrenzten Wert und deshalb braucht die
Ukraine westliche Kampfflugzeuge damit
man auch westliche Munition verschießen
kann die erstens im Westen noch
vorhanden ist und zweit wo wir über die
Produktionskapazitäten verfügen das
heißt für uns der Nachschub
berechenbarer und planbarer ist für die
Ukraine was sie verschießen kann was wir
liefern können als wenn man sich
irgendwo gebrauchte russische Raketen
auf dem Weltmarkt zusammenraffen
muss es ist aber natürlich F16 nicht
gleich F16 die F16 die jetzt zugesagt
wurden die sind auch ältere Modelle das
sind Geräte aus den 70er Jahren dieen
einzige Jahr noch ein bisschen
modernisiert wurden die haben auch
Radargeräte die nicht allzu weit reichen
die natürlich in einigen Punkten und
graduell besser sind als das was die
Ukraine jetzt verwendet
die aber was sowohl was die was die
Verwendung von luftluft als auch
luftbodenwaffen angeht nicht nicht
unbedingt die letzte Generation an an
Waffen verschießen werden können
hier gab es vom Sprecher der
ukrainischen Luftwaffe eine Meldung dass
diese Geräte äh
modernisiert werden ich weiß jetzt aber
leider nicht genau was diese
Modernisierung betrifft ob das nur ein
Update ist von von
ein Check der der rüpfe oder ob man sie
wirklich auch ein neues Radar oder
bessere Störsender bekommen
das das weiß ich leider Gottes selber
auch nicht aber es ist das Problem es
sind ältere Muster neuere Muster vor
allen Dingen aus den USA werden hier
natürlich besser das zweite ist ich habe
schon angesprochen und für diese
Kampflugzeuge müssen wir Munition
bereitstellen das betrifft die gesamte
Allianz
das Gute an der F16 ist dass fast jedes
Stück Munition das in der NATO
verschossen wird
für dieses Fluggerät zertifiziert ist
weil im Grunde weil die meisten Staaten
dieses dieses Flugzeugmuster verwenden
zwar oft in moderneren Varianten aber
aber zumindest jeder und und
dementsprechend es
ähm äh sozusagen die Erfahrung hier gibt
aber muss ich natürlich dann auch einen
Plan zurechtlegen wer liefert was in
welcher Quantität und in welcher dauern
wenn der Krieg länger geht wie
beschaffen wir das nach wie produzieren
wir nach wie wie steigern wir die
Produktion damit wir das Gut ersetzen
und auch weiter liefern können und dazu
komme ich meine Erwartungen an das
nächste Ramstein Meeting wäre eine
vernünftige
arbeitsteilige Strategie zu entwickeln
wie man die Ukraine langfristig
unterstützt es sind diese ganzen
politischen Erklärungen bombastischen
Erklärungen wer jetzt was liefert und
der versucht sich gegenseitig zu
übertreffen mit irgendwelchen
Ankündigungen
mittlerweile überhaupt nicht mehr recht
weil die Ankündigungen dann of ein Jahr
brauchen bis sie äh verwirklicht werden
lieber in den Ankündigungen tief stapeln
aber vernünftig arbeitsteilig Vorgehen
nicht nur in die in den eigenen
Hinterhof schauen was man noch ein
Altgerät hat sondern auch schauen was
kann ich denn produzieren was kann ich
denn bauen wo kann ich wo kann ich
Ersatzteile liefern welches System kann
ich der Ukraine helfen nachhaltig zu
betreiben und dann einen gemeinsamen
Plan entwickeln wie wir das in der
Allianz dieser 50 Staaten die hier von
Munition bis zu schweren Gerät alles
mögliche liefern ein vernünftigen
Lieferplan durchkriegen das wäre
wirklich meine Erwartung und meine
Hoffnung für das nächste Ramstein
treffen Herr Gresser jetzt haben wir
darüber gesprochen was es bräuchte was
die Ukraine bräuchte an nachschuban
Lieferung und woran es fehlt was glauben
Sie denn das vielleicht noch
abschließend kurz womit wird die Ukraine
tatsächlich in naher Zukunft rechnen
können die F16 werden schon kommen also
die Pilotentraining ist schon relativ
weit fortgeschritten und das Fluggerät
gibt's
auch ich ich hoffe dass gerade der
kommissionsplan zur Beschaffung von
Artilleriemunition jetzt langsam Wirkung
zeigt also wie gesagt da wurde ja viel
Zeit damit verloren die genauen
Modalitäten zwischen den Mitgliedstaaten
auszuhandeln und der komm wer was darf
und wer was nicht darf aber im September
wurden die Verträge gemacht und
Artilleriemunition braucht so in der
Regel 6 bis 9 Monate bis man sie
produziert das heißt das wird im
Frühjahr hoffentlich dann auf
europäischer Seite Berg aufgehen
m mehr gepanzerte Kampf und
Gefechtsfahrzeuge insbesondere
Schützenpanzer würde ich mir wünschen es
gibt da Gerüchte dass noch ein paar
kommen werden
gepanzerte Fahrzeuge bei dem vor allen
Dingen was russischer Seite an
Artillerie verschossen wird ist sind
enorm wichtig um Leute rein und raus aus
der Front zu bringen
um
Reserven einsetzen zu können
und haben sich also gerade schützen
Panzer mit einer halbwegst tauglichen
nachttauglichen Optik und einer
stabilisierten Maschinenkanone als
extrem wichtig er wiesen
auch der deutsche mer obwohl er schon
älteres Semester ist
vielleicht legen die Amerikaner noch ein
schufel bradle drauf das wäre enorm
wichtig Gustav gressel Militärexperte
beim European Council on Foreign
Relations vielen Dank für das Gespräch
und ihre Zeit heute abend vielen
herzlichen
Dank soweit unser Ukraine Update in
dieser Woche aktuelle Infos und auch
Hintergründe und Analysen zum Krieg in
der Ukraine findet ihr wie immer in
unserer ZDF heute App danke euch für
heute fürs zuschauen für eure Fragen und
bis zum nächsten
Mal